do you want to play a game well how
about this
watch spyro the book of saw and see how
many easter eggs you can find
sure the movie central case may be a
little too easy to solve
especially for viewers who are used to
puzzling out all the twists in the
source series sprawling
and convoluted mythology but thankfully
that's not the only mystery lurking in
the 9th entry
in the ever-growing franchise drawing
detective zeke bankston for the latest
jigsaw copycat
you'll find plenty of nods to pass soar
installments
as well as a few other movies if you
know where to look like the killer
itself the references and spiral can be
fairly elusive
which is why we've given you a head
start these are a few of the small
details hidden in director
darren lynn bausman's latest horror
flick but make sure you keep your eyes
peeled for others
per sword tradition this is one test you
really really don't want to fail
plot-wise spiral the book of sore
doesn't have much to do with previous
sore films
the killer in spiral is inspired by john
cramer better known to the world as a
serial killer jigsaw and uses part of
his iconography but he has a decidedly
different identity and motivation
and yet spiral is still part of the sore
universe
and is not totally void of references to
past movies
john kramer's face shows up in
photographs and his name is dropped a
few times
as our offhand references says
apprentices as saw fans know he has a
bunch of them
look carefully and you'll also catch a
framed photo of a tricycle
which is a signature ride of kramer's
puppet billy
but the connection between spiral and
its predecessor could go even deeper
early in the film crooked detective
fitch ends up in a trap that rips his
fingers clean off
well on reddit one viewer thinks there's
a diagram of the same trap
hidden all the way back in saw two about
57 minutes into saw two
there's a close-up of kramer's bulletin
board which features designs of his
deadly devices
on the right you can see a schematic
featuring a person with his arms
shackled and outstretched
like features are on the left the
drawings of a helmet
that look a lot like the headpiece fitch
wears right before his demise
after years of filling out the cast with
relatively lesser known actors
spiral is a sore movie anchored by two
very recognizable faces
chris rock who plays detective zeke
banks is one of the most popular
stand-up comics in the world
and a veteran actor with roles extending
from lethal weapon 4 to the fourth
season of fargo
and them playing as father marcus it's
samuel jackson
a legendary actor who's been in well
just about everything
you want to play games still if you're
going to list jackson's most iconic
roles
his turn in pulp fiction has to be near
the top of the list
in quentin tarantino's groundbreaking
crime film jackson plays jules winfield
a hit man who alongside his partner
vincent vega
finds himself wrapped up in an intricate
plot involving a crime boss a mysterious
briefcase
two petty thugs and a whole heap of
trouble
damn jimmy this some serious gourmet
thanks in large part to jackson's
performance pulp fiction remains a
favorite
and one of the most quoted movies ever
to this day
as such it's awfully nice of spiral the
book of saw to pay tribute to one of
jackson's most memorable on-screen
appearances
the door to the south metro police
station's cold case room
bears the manufacturer name vincent and
jules even the movie's cast
that's definitely not a coincidence
darren lynn bausman who directed spyral
is no stranger to either horror or the
sore franchise
as the director of saw 2 saw 3 and saw 4
balzman helped to define the visual
style of the series
he's also the director behind other
movies steeped in the horror genre
like repo the genetic opera the devil's
carnival
11 11 11 and plenty more but that's not
all
over the past five years or so bausman
also added a number of immersive theater
experiences to his resume
each one of which brought audience
members into the narrative itself
in projects like the tension experience
and the lust experience for example
participants played a years long
augmented reality game
about a fictional and very evil
organization
before heading to a live two-hour show
where they interacted with myriad
characters
and uncovered more about the story may
or may not
interact with leonard over here who uh
he's not a guy you want to uh upset
let's sit down now we're gonna play a
game come on
theater macabre had a script that was
over one thousand pages long
and featured multiple paths through its
story all depending on which choices
individual audience members made
it sounds like cool and provocative
stuff so it shouldn't be too surprising
that bozeman paid tribute to it in
spiral
when zeke and his fellow officers head
under the bridge to look for fitch's
body
you can see the tension experience logo
spray painted on a pillar the blessed
experience and theater macabre symbols
are also hidden on the spiral sets
although you'll have to look very
very hard to find them check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you